lucy is on twitter and says dave how
come you never consider bankruptcy if
individuals are deep in a financial
crisis well a lot of different reasons
Lucy I don't yell at somebody if they've
been through a bankruptcy I've been
through one I'm not proud of that but in
my 20s I borrowed way too much money and
that's what started this whole movement
of ours is we quit borrowing money and
we had to learn how to handle money
after we went broke because I was stupid
now not everybody that follows
bankruptcy does it because they're
stupid but I was and a lot of times the
stuff you get yourself into is stupid
Larry Burkett used to say that financial
problems are not the problem they're the
symptom you're disorganized immature
impulsive don't know how money works
greedy you're something that causes you
to make a series of decisions that put
you into bankruptcy court and bankruptcy
court does not fix the thing that puts
you there it just fixes the debt you're
still there after bankruptcy with all of
your problems I was still there with all
of my problems and so bankruptcy is in a
very real sense treating the symptom
that's problem number one with me
recommending bankruptcy problem number
two with me recommending bankruptcy is
it's a life-altering life scarring
decision and it's a decision you should
make on your own not because some gamma
radio told you to it's in the same
category as divorce you should never go
through a divorce because someone else
told you to that's a decision you need
to come to because it's a life-altering
life scarring process it's not something
you'd wish on anybody that you care
about and I wouldn't wish bankruptcy on
anybody that I care about
and so I will not have someone say I
filed bankruptcy because Dave Ramsey
told me to and so that's why I don't say
hey just go file bankruptcy
because a lot of times it doesn't fix
what's going on number two its life
scarring and I don't want you having had
me make that decision for you you make
the decision on your own I'm gonna love
you wherever you are I'm gonna walk with
you I'm gonna tell you the truth and I'm
gonna walk with you the third reason is
a lot of bankruptcies are filed that
didn't have to be there's a lot of times
there's a way out and people just get
beat up and beat on and lose hope and
they just can't see the way out
so that's another reason I don't jump on
bankruptcy is the answer but I'm not
against bankruptcy I just don't I'm not
mad at you for filing bankruptcy like
I'm not mad at you found divorce I just
wouldn't wish it on you because it's a
horrible thing to go through it